behind the left-handed slants of tyler
anderson who pitched for the giants last
year and night in the night out uh some
nights he's good enough and some nights
he's extraordinary and really more
toward the latter here in his uh recent
outings 2-2 a swing and a miss he struck
him out there we go a bunch of fastballs
and then he pulled the string with a
nice looking change up down here's ruff
ruff is had won it bad in the series
he's over one
rough into deep center field
reynolds looking up
out of here
and the giants take a one-nothing lead
well that's why darren ruff is in the
lineup against a left-handed pitcher
that's where he does most his damage
especially the long ball is off
left-handers and on the road he's been
extremely
productive on the road this year and you
knew off the bat that was going to go a
long way two away for wilmer flores
he gets underneath this one and it's
right in front of home plate
and it's gonna fall one two three four
five pirates in the area here's brandon
crawford getting a second chance so to
speak in this inning
crawford hits a high drive to right and
out of here he's done it again
my goodness is he seeing the ball well
that ball was crushed and he takes the
home run lead for the giants
and that's how you make that pop-up hurt
absolutely it is johnny cueto is 21-4
against the pirates well that's a good
thing right well you talk about ownage's
his hitters against pitchers i think
that's ownage against a team
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one out here's newman
newman
sharply out to center field first pace
hit for the bucks and that'll bring up
reynolds reynolds hitting 287.
he backed it up and he got him same spot
same location same result pirates now
have a threat here in the first inning
first and third nobody hurt yet you
still have two outs now polanco if he
runs into one here we got a tie ball
game
high in
the air to right center field and deep
going back on the ball of slater at the
wall he'll make the catch polanco
just missed a game-tying home run second
inning coming up masali will lead off
batting just 106. kurt casalli he sends
one deep out to left field gamble back
on the run and it catches him
as he was on the run uh he kind of
caught it two-handed at his neck moving
talking to second with two outs for
austin slater the pitch swung on lofted
to left
to his left gamma weights on it
and he'll make the catch that ends the
inning so the walk left on we got the
third inning coming up for you a pop-up
hit and an infield grounder hit for
wilmer flores he's at first roughs it
third one out for brandon crawford who
homered back in that first inning the
pitch home and a swing and a high pop up
in the infield anderson
cut underneath it for a moment it's
craig to take charge and he'll make the
catch for the second half two down and
now it's up to dubon for the giants to
cash this rally in
slash into right field of base hit
so that'll knock in rough and that'll
make brandon crawford feel a lot better
big hit for mauricio dubon
four-nothing giants bottom half of
ending number three here's tyler
anderson who's one for 15. shatters his
bat sends one into right falling faster
down for a hit look at this tyler
anderson's just going to take matters
into his own hand now base runner with
the top of the order coming up for the
second time and the very tough adam
frazier
frazier slashes one liner to third
caught and it's going to be a double
play as longoria throws across to double
up anderson frazier hit the first pitch
right on a line
very solidly but right to longoria and
anderson had taken his lead and was just
frozen didn't go back had nowhere to go
we'll go to the fourth inning runner in
scoring position for austin slater his
set and the pitch
swing and a miss a lunging cut on the
low curveball slater is struck out for a
second time tonight the fifth strikeout
for anderson three two to rough swing in
a miss struck him out that time got the
fastball in and off and struck him out
swinging to end the inning bottom of the
fourth inning four nothing giants base
hit for reynolds to start the pirates
fourth inning and now to bring up
stallings who already has a hit this one
on the ground is short crawford nice
play to get one and the giants turn two
what a double play well two and two
innings in a row with double plays just
done the done different ways that one a
lot more difficult way to loved it
that'll bring up polanco with a little
hesitation move molanco golfs that one
up there into much shallower center
field dubon
what range from second base slater broke
back and that left up to dubon who's
playing at second base
and that'll do a nice play by mauricio
dubois fifth inning coming up it's
four-nothing giants
have second and third nobody out so
here's gonzalez who shoots this one back
up the middle off the foot of plato and
throw to first with plato covering is
not in time and a run comes in
and the giants are going to have the
umpires take a look at this oh you got
him if he was on the back he got him oh
that's going to be tough that's tough to
see right there ow so that's big for the
giants because that's the first out of
the inning so instead of nobody out now
there's one out and i tom will face
cueto he'll stay in
tom
laces one to right field gamma will
score and tom a pinch hit single has cut
the lead in half to 4-2 so the tying run
is now at second base johnny cueto is
out of this game giants going to the
bullpen and will bring in right-hander
zach littell that one is hit to right
not that deep we'll see darren ruff is
going to make the catch here comes tom
trying to score the throw there tag and
he got him at home what a throw by
darren ruff on one hop right to the
catcher rough with a good throw casale
with a great tag and that's how this
inning is going to end
the pirates score a pair but that's it
we'll head to the sixth so casalli will
accept the one out free pass and that'll
bring up talkman who's walked twice
talkman drives one to deep right field
this one is on its way and it is gone
well up into the bleachers a towering
home run for mike talkman is second in a
giants uniform
and the giants grab those two runs right
back at six to two that's a momentum
killer we'll head to the bottom of the
six ryan reynolds will start it
that one was hammered to right field and
it is off the top of the wall ruff plays
the carom he's going to try to throw out
another pirate and he didn't
wow real close darren ruff almost had
his second outfield assist in as many
innings
so the umpires are converging around
that would be the one replay that may
turn this thing around right on the hip
there that was that was a decent look i
didn't see whether the foot had hit the
bag right there he might might have
gotten him
out and it is
[Applause]
playing right field in pittsburgh
looking like roberto clemente
on the bottom of the 7th the pirates
once again as they have many times
tonight with some runners aboard kevin
newman against camilo duvall
and swinging a line drive out to rough
in right toward the line can't get their
fair ball base hit here comes gonzalez
to score stokes into third rbi single
kevin newman well now the base is full
of bucks for stallings and the dirk goes
away from casalli and everyone's gonna
move up stokes with the belly flop slide
at home it's six to four
and the tying runs in scoring position
for the bucks here in the seventh the
base hit ties the game now yep base it
ties the game there's the pitch and
ripped down the line
[Applause]
here comes the second run
stallings
moves into second base with a double and
the pirates have tied the game up it's a
game-tying double for jacob stallings
six six here in the seventh whole new
ballgame as we go to the eighth after
the hit by wade as a walk by slater and
a runner in scoring position for the
giants so ruff is going to hit
starts him off with a curve just missed
low for ball one
well he's not missing by much
that's derek shelton and he's been
thrown from the game as mark ripperjer
has ejected derrick shelton derek
shelton's coming out and he is arguing
with home plate umpire mark ripper who
has just ejected it from the ball game
after all those calls that are very
close and not going the way of the
pirates 2-2 pitch
and he struck him out
right down the middle from stratton
chris stratton strands two so we'll go
to the bottom of the ninth now a single
to begin the ninth so now one away and
brian reynolds steps to the plate
yank down the left field line this is
trouble it's a fair ball headed into the
corner frazier coming around to third
cochman finally comes up with a ball
here comes the relay home the tag and he
is out at home plate the giants cut down
the winning run at home talkman to
crawford to casalli two down
stallings up of course had the big hit
back in the seventh inning to tie the
game up trying to come through again
stallings hits one deep to left field
and this one is gone
[Applause]
for jacob stallings what is happening
stallings
who tied the game in the seventh wins it
here in the ninth
what an amazing couple of games for the
pirates
[Applause]